i want to thank you first of all the
chancellor renee walter and the uw
superior students and faculty for having
us and senator baldwin obviously and
mayor payne and all the labor partners
and workers as well who are with us
today
you know it's clear from the president's
speech last night that he's committed to
building
a an economy that works for everyone
and guess what investing in our
infrastructure
is at the heart of that
and that's why we've been working to
invest in our infrastructure here in
wisconsin our roads and bridges in
wisconsin have suffered for years and
years because of lack of a meaningful
investment in our state's transportation
infrastructure
but when i ran for governor i ran on the
promise that we're going to fix the damn
roads
[Applause]
and i'm glad to see that uh we've
improved more than
1770 miles of highways and bridges and
more than and and more than 1250 bridges
in fact if you laid out those highways
and the end you could just about drive
to platteville and denver and back how
about that wisconsin
and we are also able to keep all 375
transportation projects on track during
the 2020 construction season which meant
that we are able to receive 105 million
dollars in federally redistributed
highway dollars from other states
[Applause]
to
to invest back in our infrastructure and
thanks to those other states i know
minnesota used theirs up so it wasn't
minnesota keeping these uh projects on
on tax contract we're not only
important about improving our roads but
ensuring people are able to keep working
and businesses were able to stay afloat
and folks were able to provide for
themselves and their families
and that right there is the crux of this
issue by investing in infrastructure
we're not just
investing in safer and more sustainable
roads and bridges we're investing in a
stronger and more resilient economy and
in jobs and small businesses and
communities it's it's the connecting dot
we're headed in the right direction but
we have fought far more to do and we're
going to need help from the federal
government to do that
thankfully
help is on the way
with bipartisan with this bipartisan
infrastructure law
there are several billion dollars coming
our way to build on the progress that
we've made in fixing our roads and
highways
this is once in a generation investment
folks and we are hoping to put that
investment to good use with projects
like reconstructing the blockneck bridge
this bridge is one of only two
connections between duluth and superior
and more than thirty thousand vehicles
cross that every single day
but sixty years of exposure to the
elements that led to corrosion and
damage
and in since 2018 the bridge has been
required projects is required to be
re-fixed every four years and it's a and
have annual inspections and without
significant additional funding the
bridge will continue to decay and
eventually be closed
thankfully the federal bipartisan and
infrastructure law is providing at least
225 million dollars for each of the
states to for bridge replacement and
rehabilitation projects and will be able
to compete for the bridge investment
program for larger projects and after
today governor walls and i had a chance
to talk to the president about this
project and i hope the president might
be able to put in a good word for us
[Applause]
and this is bigger it's bigger than just
the bridge between our two states
governor wallace and i know that
investing in our infrastructure is about
building a supportive future that kind
of future that we want for our states
and improving the quality of life for
wisconsinites minnesotans and folks
across this country look forward to
continuing this partnership between our
states and the biden administration as
we work to build on that future so that
again
thank you president biden thank you
leaders from washington that came to be
with us today
and thank you all for being here
[Applause]
you
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen please welcome the
president of the united states joe biden
accompanied by the first lady of the
united states dr jill biden and vice
president of the international union of
painters and allied trades local 106
gordon smith
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hi
uh
thank you um
well and that's the band i presume right
thank you to the band
great job
job you know it's wonderful to be in
superior and duluth and places that mean
so much to joe and me
and with all of our friends
governor walsh tim and gwen and we were
yes we were just together at a child
care event just a couple weeks ago
tony and kathy
thank you for welcoming us
and thank you to all of our elected
leaders so we traveled here uh just an
hour ago i guess from washington
and uh you really have a great bunch of
representatives with lots of energy and
they're a lot of fun to travel with
[Applause]
on another cold winter morning you know
much like today
i held our family bible and watched my
husband take the oath of office
in that moment
he was the man i fell in love with so
many years ago
a father
okay
i guess i don't tell him enough
a father of two boys standing in the
wreckage of unthinkable loss
who stitched a broken family together
with grit
and grace
he was the man who took home the train
home to delaware every night
because he knew that showing up for the
smallest moments
can sometimes mean the most
he was the senator who learned that you
know to get up when he got knocked down
and fight even harder for what he knows
is right
the vice president whose steadfast
counsel helped guide our country country
through many storms
that day he was joe
and then suddenly
he became
something else too
the president of the united
[Applause]
states it felt like americans across the
country were holding their breath
in the aftermath of four years of chaos
but as joe stood there shoulders back
eyes shining with fierce optimism
i could see his determination
to bring us together
to lead us forward to a better america
and every day since
he has worked to do
just that
millions of families have been able to
send their children back to school
and find jobs and catch up on bills
they've been able to
finally take a breath
we still have a long way to go
our world
faces
incredible challenges
but things are so much better
you were right to put your faith in joe
biden a year ago
[Applause]
because in the face of an uncertainty he
is unshakable
despite
deep divides at home and abroad
he knows how to bring people together
how to rally the world when tyrants
reach for power
he never loses sight of what this is all
about
the people he serves
when joe goes to bed at night and when
he wakes up in the morning
he all he thinks about is how to make
life better for you and your family
it's just who he is
it's who he's always been
he will never stop
working for you
he will never
stop
fighting for you thank you
now i want to bring up our next speaker
a painter
a father
a mentor
a man who knows the meaning of union
strong
[Applause]
he's worked hard to help make this area
a better place to live and we're happy
to have him with us today gordon smith
[Applause]
my name is gordy smith and i'm a member
of the international union of painters
and allied trades district council 82
local 106.
i am honored to be with you here today
i've been a painter for 31 years
but i started as a non-union painter
i became a member of the iupat when our
shop was organized in the early 1990s
i was younger at the time and didn't
understand unions
but taking that action really made my
life better
for me and my family
[Applause]
as a union painter i've had the
opportunity work on many different types
of projects from mines and power plants
to bridges and commercial construction
over time i grew to appreciate my union
membership more and more
being part of the iupat
meant that my
wife barbara and i were able to raise
our son michael and help put him through
college in a certified auto tech program
now he has a good union job too
being
[Applause]
being part of the iupat has given me not
only just a job but a career
every worker even you
can have the same opportunity i've had
for many years those of us in the
building and construction trades
have heard the promise of
massive
infrastructure investment but those
promises were never kept
president joe biden and his team have
finally delivered on that promise
[Applause]
the bipartisan infrastructure bill gives
us the opportunity to rebuild our
crumbling infrastructure and put another
generation of people to work in the
process
throughout the midwest we have thousands
of bridges like the blockneck bridge
here in superior
in need of repair
the investment in the nation's
infrastructure is vital to our
communities
everyone needs to be able to safely
to go
to work school and family events
i'm proud that here and across the
country
my sisters and brothers are at work
coding these bridges
and it's not just to make them look good
it's to keep them strong
safe and protected from corrosion
one of my favorite things about being
part of the painters union is the
opportunity to mentor younger brothers
and sisters
who are serving their apprenticeship
i get to teach them skills and pass a
trade that they can take pride in and
will provide for their families
the resources
resources that will come into wisconsin
to rebuild public facilities and
transportation infrastructure
will provide stable careers for the next
generation of northland iupat members
and you can join us
i'm not someone who often gets up in
front of people to share a piece of my
story so i certainly never thought one
day
i'd share the stage with the president
[Applause]
i am so proud to be here with all with
all of you today
and a president
who doesn't just talk about fixing
things
but puts his words into action
[Applause]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen it is my honor to
introduce
the president of the united states joe
biden
you know i've
got to tell you a story
hadn't planned on this
when jill and i met and fell in love
she let me know her favorite day in the
calendar it was valentine's day
the first valentine's day
that we were together when i was vice
president
the vice president's office faces
the eisenhower building a big granite
building
you see on the other side of the white
house
and there's triple set of stairs coming
down
from that building and they come right
they look right in the vice president's
office as you come down
and the press comes down that way all
the time
and so the night before
this thanksgiving this uh
valentine's day the first one
jill got a typical professor teacher
form she got
the
maintenance guys to bring up a 16-foot
ladder
and on i think there are a total of uh
i don't know 19 panes of each in each
window big panes of glass
and with that erasable
uh paint you can have
she put a heart on every single of the
five windows four windows
saying
joe loves jill
and uh
that night my press guy got a call from
cbs morning news would i be on cbs more
morning news
to talk about valentine's day he said
you ought to do it
so i did and while we're getting ready
to
while we're getting ready
in the office all the lights are down
and i think i i think i've told my
colleagues in the house this sentence
this story
while they're
as dark they're fixing the lights and
i'm sitting knee to knee
with a woman named juju chang who used
to
be work for cbs
and while they're fixing the lights she
looks at me she says
everybody says you and your wife have a
great love affair
and i said i think so and i said but
everybody knows i love her more than she
loves me
and she responded my word that's what
everybody says
and then she said
she had done a study
that she had been on i guess two or
three parts on the morning show over a
period of weeks before
and i think don't hold me to this i
think it was i think it was yale and
stanford had done this study what makes
marriages last the longest and the most
romantic
you can always tell when
the couple was not only in love but
there was romantic no matter how old
they get
and
she said you know what it is
i said no she said this one the husband
loves the wife more
i want to tell you julie this was worth
the trip to come out here today
thank you
thank you thank you thank you
if the secret service agents weren't
sworn to secrets that they could tell
you they've never heard anything like
that said from a podium by joe
i love wisconsin in minnesota
[Applause]
hello wisconsin
can you hear me across the river hello
minnesota
i'm jill biden's husband joe
and gordon thank you for that
introduction governor evers and governor
walls and thank you both for uh for
welcoming to both your states and uh mr
mayor jim payne thank you for the
passport
and uh
and emily uh from duluth mayor duluth
when we got off the plane she i don't
think she had a coat on she had on
she i mean i tell you're tough kid i
thank you for the passport to both your
cities
and thanks for three outstanding
senators and i mean that sincerely all
friends tammy baldwin
amy globachar tina smith
and congressman mark pacone and ron kind
you got a hell of a delegation
all of you
last night i was with your senators
representatives along with their
colleagues in congress
to speak about the state of the union
together
we sent an unmistakable signal to
ukraine into the world that we the
united states of america stand with the
ukrainian people we stand with them
[Applause]
and vladimir putin
vladimir putin's latest attack on
ukraine is premeditated and unprovoked
he's rejected repeated efforts at
diplomacy
he thought the west and nato
wouldn't respond
he thought they could divide us at home
but he was wrong
we were ready
we spent countless hours unifying the
european allies
we counted russia's lies and truth we
countered them by letting them know what
was being planned
and now the free world is holding him
accountable
putin is now isolated from the world
more than ever
and will continue to aid ukrainian
people
as they defend their country
and help ease their suffering in the
process
when history
of this era is written
ukraine will have left russia weaker
and the rest of the world stronger
folks
[Applause]
they're amazing
they're amazing people you see those
scenes i've been to ukraine i've spoken
to the rod i've spent much time there
over the years
they're amazing people
and we're growing stronger at home as
well
as i said last night
there is no greater testament to the
grit and resilience of the american
people than the progress you've all made
in the middle of a pandemic
thanks to the american rescue plan we
lifted the country out of crisis
created 6.5 million jobs
more jobs than any american has ever
created in a single year
our economy
grew our economy grew
at 5.7 the strongest growth in 40 years
vice president harris and i we ran for
office with a new economic vision for
america
invest in america
educate the american people
grow the workforce and build an economy
from the bottom up in the middle out not
just from the top down
because we know that when the middle
class grows the poor have a way up and
the wealthy do very very well everyone
does fine
my rescue plan reflects that vision
and that's uh that was just the first
step
we also had to invest in the country
itself
america used to have the best
infrastructure in the world the best
bridges roads airports etc
now our infrastructure ranks number 13
in the world
according to the world economic forum
you can't compete for jobs in the 21st
century if we don't fix that
that's why it was so important to pass
the bipartisan infrastructure law
most sweeping investment to rebuild
america in all american history
bipartisan
i want to thank your senators and
representatives here today for helping
lead that charge and that was literally
what they did lead the charge
when i signed that infrastructure law
100 days ago we already had
we already had the ground run run we hit
the ground running announcing
100 billion dollars in new investments
to create jobs for millions of americans
modernizing our roads our airports our
ports our waterways
and we'll do it we'll do it all to
withstand the devastating effects of
climate and promote environmental
justice in the process
you know
we're building
a national network of 500 000
electric vehicle charging stations so
americans can own electric cars reduce
pollution and lead the way to clean
energy future
we're going to replace
that legislation is going to allow us to
replace all the lead pipes in this
country so every child can turn on a
phosphate home or in school and drink
clean water
[Applause]
the days of having to pull your child up
outside of mcdonald's to do their
homework because there's no internet in
your home
and no internet in your region and we
provide affordable high-speed internet
to every american
urban rural suburban tribal
and that's big for rural communities it
helps farmers engage in precision
agriculture knowing when they should
sell their products and so much more
as i've announced last night
this year we're going to start fixing 65
000 miles of highway and 1 500 bridges
in disrepair
your governor's going to use some of
that funding for this law to modernize
one of the most important bridges in
this region the one you look out the
window and see here
look the blatnick bridge
you all know this bridge well it's a
bridge that connects our cities and our
your cities and your state
a bridge that carries people to work and
carries goods out of your port
you know when the husky oil refinery
exploded in superior back in 2018
this bridge was one that many of you
took to get your families to safety
and you so you know it matters
but you may not know
as was mentioned earlier the bridge is
61 years old at the end of its useful
life
the corrosion over the years has lowered
the weight it can sustain and safely
handle
by the way i wasn't long ago you may
have seen in all the news clips i was in
pittsburgh
i arrived in pittsburgh a little early
but thank god we arrived when we did
because
just
three two hours earlier a bridge that is
as high off the ground as this bridge
collapsed completely
completely you should have seen it it
was astounding to look at
for the same reasons this bridge is in
trouble
and guess what thank god there are only
a few vehicles on the bridge no one was
killed you should have seen it it was
astounding how no one died
had it occurred just three hours later
you would have had all those school
buses all those children all the
thousands of people across that bridge
there's so many bridges in the this is
the united states of america for god's
sake
so many bridges in a similar condition
and that is outside it's this bridge
also has outdated design
tight curves led to higher than average
crash rates on this bridge
the bridge isn't alone
there are 700 excuse me 979 bridges in
wisconsin
661 bridges in minnesota in poor
condition
along with nearly 7 000 miles of highway
between your two states that need repair
and now after years of talking about
infrastructure we're finally getting it
done
by the way
instead of infrastructure week we're
going to have an infrastructure decade
[Applause]
decade
look
back in january
i announced the largest investment our
bridges in american history a total of
40 billion dollars in funding for
bridges improvement 40 billion
including 12.5 billion
to fix the most economically significant
bridges in this country like the
blatnick bridge
and on top of that
top of that over the next five years
based on formula funding
the bipartisan infrastructure law will
provide minnesota an estimated
5.4 billion dollars
and wisconsin 5.4 billion dollars
for highways and bridges
because sure don't want you to miss
any of the vikings packer games
oh man you guys talk to one another
well we don't much in philadelphia and
pittsburgh but that's a different story
in addition
even more funding's available to the
states through competitive programs so i
believe
your governor they're going to put their
heads together and secure the funding
they need to finally get this done
putting hard-working americans
on the job rebuilding this bridge with
u.s steel
keeping commerce flowing freely
and keeping families in the spirit of
duluth safer and better connected but
this association is about much more than
the bridge
or the bridge is it's about opportunity
opportunity
across the region and across the country
investing in your port your airports and
more this isn't just about bridges and
highways it goes much beyond that
and i'm here at the intersection of all
of these things
your airport your porch the river
the lake
the bridges the highways it's also about
the historic investments we're making in
the great lakes
i don't have to tell anybody here
i went to school
and i grew up on one that not grew up
but i lifeguard on one of the great
lakes out of syracuse new york
great lakes provide drinking water for
41 million people
you support they support more than 1.3
million jobs
and two weeks ago i visited lorraine
ohio
and i announced an investment
something we've been promising a long
time all the places have to be repaired
both in canada and in the united states
but i announced
one billion dollars
from the bipartisan infrastructure law
accelerating cleanup of sites where
polluted waters and wastewater
treatments have given the great lakes
and put them at great risk
including the st louis river
which flows between your states
one study found that for every dollar
spending cleaning up the great lakes we
generate three to four dollars in
economic benefit
it's a good investment
and it's badly there's more fresh water
in these lakes than any other single
place in the whole
world folks
[Applause]
it's not only the investment we're
making the great lakes
on the opposite end of lake superior
from where we stand
the sew locks connect this lake to other
great lakes
those locks are a gateway connecting the
things that make we make here in this
country to the rest of the world
7 000 vessels
and ninety percent of america's iron ore
move through those talks every year
that aura makes nearly all the
high-strength steel that goes into
american-made cars and appliances
in january
in january
and announced nearly 500 million dollars
to upgrade the sioux locks
moving goods faster while reducing costs
creating a hell of a lot of jobs and
maintaining them
it's all we're also doubling the
investment we're making in our ports
including the port of duluth superior
which was awarded 8.4 million dollar
grant to make critical improvements
along
along with the 12 million investment for
the army corps of engineers to
reconstruct the dock wall the vessel
yard and the luth harbor basin
look
these investments will help fortify our
port while strengthening the local
economy
when we use taxpayers dollars
to build america
we buy america
[Applause]
for a long long time since the 30s
there's been a law saying
when the president united states spends
taxpayers dollars
on american projects whether it's an
aircraft carrier or railings in a public
building
when they buy those products
they should buy america
but there's been an exception in the law
up to now
it says that if in fact the product is
not immediately available in the united
states they can buy it abroad
the federal government spends about 600
billion a year to keep this country safe
and secure
and there's been that law has been on
the books i said for almost a century
taxpayers dollars
but guess what
in my administration the entirety of it
from beginning to end
has to be built and made in america to
be used
not a joke
we're actually doing it
we will buy
american make sure everything from the
deck of an aircraft carrier
the steel on the bridge is made in
america
look around the country
american manufacturing is coming back
once again we're seeing the pride that
comes with stamping products made in
america
companies are choosing to build
their new factories here
when just a few years ago just a few
years ago they wouldn't build abroad
ohio senator sherrod brown as my
senate colleagues will tell you
he had a great saying when we announced
what was happening in iowa and ohio i
should say
he said it's time to bury the label rust
belt
well that's what we're doing
as i said last night
intel
intel is building a 20 billion dollar
semiconductor mega site just outside of
columbus ohio
up to eight state-of-the-art factories
in one place and by the way the people
who've been working in those factories
you know what he told me they're gonna
average pay is gonna be
135
000
a year
10 000 jobs in most of them union jobs
making the computer chip the size of a
fingertip
the power of the world in our everyday
lives smartphones the internet
technology that doesn't even exist today
and if congress passes the bipartisan
innovation act
that on their desk now
intel is ready to increase their
investment from 20 billion
to 100 billion dollars
intel alone
alone
ford has invested 11 billion dollars to
build electric vehicles
creating 11 000 new good paying jobs
across the country
gm
is making the largest investment in its
history seven billion dollars to build
electric vehicles
creating 4 000 jobs in michigan
union pacific railroad when i was in
pittsburgh i i met the the the folks who
run the union pacific railroad just
announced the purchase of the largest
ever purchase of electric locomotives
made in erie pennsylvania in the same
plant by the way
that the guy who turned on our lights
built a factory
all told
we've created 369 000 new manufacturing
jobs in america just last year
[Applause]
don't tell me we can't be a
manufacturing center again we can
we have to keep this story going
but we know that despite this historic
recovery too many families are still
struggling with higher costs i get it
our top priority must be getting prices
under control
look our economy roared back faster than
most predicted but the pandemic meant
businesses had a hard time hiring enough
help to keep the workers in the
production the reason why the cost of
housing went up in new housing is
because no one was there to make sure
they had the two by fours to be built
to to build the home because people
weren't in the factories
and because people were making a lot
more money than before there was a lot
of cash at hand and they did not use
that cash to go out to the restaurants
or go on vacation
they use it for hard products
and the pandemic disrupted global supply
chains
when factories close it takes longer for
goods to get from the warehouse to the
stores and prices go up
look at cars
last year there weren't enough
semiconductors to make all the cars
people wanted to buy they had the money
to buy them
but there weren't enough literally
enough cars
because we invented
the uh the uh
those chips when we went to the moon
but we didn't make them anymore
they were made in the rest of the world
so prices went way up
one third of the reason for inflation
was the cost to these additional cost of
automobiles
so we have a choice
one way to fight inflation is drive down
wages
and make americas poorer
i have a better way to fight inflation
lower your cost not your wages
[Applause]
we're going to make more cars and
semiconductors in america more
infrastructure and innovation in america
more goods moving faster and cheaper in
america more jobs that you can earn a
living a good living by here in america
instead of relying on foreign supply
chains let's make it in america again
[Applause]
there's a lot more to my plan to lower
costs and lower
and lower the deficit by the way we're
going to lower the deficit by a trillion
dollars this year
these guys talk about how they always
are worried about us spend we're
lowering the deficit no one's ever done
that
but look i've kept you long enough
there's a lot more i'm inclined to say
i don't want to get go i don't want to
get wound up here
but let me close with this look
i am truly more optimistic
about america today than i've ever been
i really mean it
we're on a path to win
the economic competition in the 21st
century to be faced with the rest of the
world
i told xi jinping who i'm told i've met
with more than any other world leader
that has never been a good bet to bet
against the american people never
given half a chance
they have never ever ever
ever let the country down
we're the only nation
that has always
turned every crisis we've faced into an
opportunity no other nation you can name
has gone through a terrible circumstance
and come out at the other end worse off
than they were before the the
circumstance occurred
we're stronger today than we're a year
ago
and we're going to be stronger a year
from now than we are today
so let's keep building let's continue to
give families a fighting chance
and let's meet this moment together
folks
one last thing i'd like to say to you
the other reason why i'm so optimistic
is because of the younger generation
you know we are a country that is very
diverse
and for the longest time and we still
have some serious resistance to
diversity in this country
but guess what
the younger generation doesn't feel that
the generation that goes to this
university
the end the generation that's in high
school and up through age 30
look at them
look at how they interact with one
another
they make no distinctions based on race
they make no distinction based on gender
think of what's happening
one of the things that i'm confident
about
is they are together and they want the
nation to be together
and one of the things i promised i would
do i've gotten criticized for but i'll
just flat out admit it and i'm not going
to stop
my administration is going to look like
america
[Applause]
for example
my administration
we have more women than we have men
a little bit
that's because all the women in my life
are smarter than i am
we also have the greatest diversity
we've ever had
look folks
there's nothing
there truly is nothing beyond our
capacity there really isn't
we're the most unique nation in the
history of the world
that we're the only nation
built on an idea
not geography
not built on a notion of of race or
religion or ethnicity
none of that fits the description of the
united states
building an idea
that we hold these truths to be
self-evident
that all women and men are created equal
and down by their creator with certain
inalienable rights
life liberty the pursuit of happiness
we've never lived up to it
we've never walked away from it
and every generation has moved that dial
closer and closer and closer
and we badly need it now
in a world that is so close
look folks
your kids are going to see more change
in the next 10 years we've seen the last
50
because of the changes in technology and
so much
more we've got to be ready
america has always been ahead of the
curve
because we do hold these truths to be
self-evident
again
we're not perfect we're not even close
but we never have walked away
and
vladimir putin
was counting on being able to split up
the united states
look
how would you feel
if you saw
crowds
storm and break down the doors of the
british parliament
kill five
cops
ninja 145
or the german bundestag
or the italian parliament
i think you'd wonder
well that's what the rest of the world
saw
it's not who we are
and now
we're proving
under pressure
that we are not that country
we're united
and folks that's how i was able we were
able to make sure we kept
europe united
and the free world united
vote in the united nations to condemn
putin
141
countries voted to do that in the u.n
general assembly
several abstained
china abstained
didn't didn't vote with him
but abstained
in the abstain
seven countries abstained i think it was
the number
they're alone
and they did what they did in my view he
did what he because he thought he could
split nato
split europe and split the united states
we're going to demonstrate to the whole
world
no one can split this country thank you
all so very much
thank you
[Music]
this
[Music]
so
[Music]
bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
good
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
it
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
so
[Music]
no
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hi
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
bye
[Music]
bye
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
bye oh
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
down
so
[Music]
[Music]
right
[Music]
foreign
[Music]